my name is Michael macmaine I am the CEO
and founder of Xavier and the creative
director on lych 'dom we've got our game
here lich dome battle mage and what
we're bringing here in this game is what
we believe is the first RPG where the
mage is an unmitigated badass and we've
done this we've accomplished this by
removing constraints that are typically
placed on mages like mana bars and
cooldowns and what we would do is
instead of you waiting around for
cooldowns or our abilities to come back
we focus on skill components we've given
you a couple of really cool defensive
abilities and we weaponize them so the
first defensive ability is your block
and when you block when you use your
right mouse button the block you ignore
half of all damage and if you time it
just right you have this galvanized
period where you're completely
invulnerable to damage and anytime
you're hit you're gonna detonate with a
deadly Nova the second defensive ability
is your blink and there's two versions
there's a quick blink which allows you
to kind of dance around the battlefield
quickly and dodge enemy attacks but if
you charge it up and you hold it you can
get a deadly Nova that will explode
either freezing or killing your enemies
so as you can see we're going through
here we're showing an example of this is
Kinesis which is about lifting enemies
off the battlefield and moving them
around and then we have a fire spell
that we're convoying up where this is a
instead of being a projectile this fire
spell is a beam that allows you to just
ignite your enemies and do this channel
defect on them in addition we have an
ice spell that's about freezing your
enemies and slowing them and causing big
big hitting damage this level that we're
looking at is mils is a maelstrom it's a
third level released in game we're in
early access this particular build is
our alpha build which is going to go
live this Monday the game is going to
release on August 26th
which is about ten weeks away so what we
have here is josh is switching over to a
different combination of spells he's
taken his fire spell out and he's added
a lightning spell and now what he wants
to do is he wants to set up this nuclear
play style so he's gonna build a
lightning spell that's a targeted spell
arrange spell that is all about D
buffing an enemy with mastery so the
first thing he's gonna do is he's gonna
find out which one of these targeted
components he wants to use so he
selected the targeted component and he's
looking at all the stats and now he says
okay I want to make this a mastery spell
so he's got this legendary mastery
augment and when he puts that in there
that defines a spell as a mastery spell
which is all about D buffing the enemy
and setting him up for huge critical
attacks in addition he's got a second
slot so he's gonna add even more mastery
so now when he hits the enemies it's
this spell is not gonna cause damage but
what it's gonna do is set them up for
extraordinary damage
so he's equip the spell and he's gonna
move into the next area here so he's got
his lightning spell all charged up and
you can see this enemy now when he hits
this enemy with this lightning spell
it's not actually causing damage but
what it's doing is it's D buffing the
enemy and setting them up for bigger
attacks and see you here this is a
control version of Layton where he
stunned his enemies so that they can't
attack him back and by comboing these
different spells together he can get
very dramatic effects so he lifts this
enemy in the air charges him up a bit
with his mastery and then closes it with
a big huge ice attack that just
obliterates the enemy in one shot now
what's interesting about this is if
you're really really good at it
you're gonna get a lot of damage that is
more damaging you need to kill the enemy
right which is overkill and a lot of
times you look at that and say well yeah
but overkill is kind of a waste right
why am i focused on that well we have a
system in place that we call synergies
and in order to accomplish a synergy
this is a like cataclysmic level event
that in this case josh has a singularity
equipped and the singularity synergy
will suck enemies in and detonate and
cause drastic amazing damage and if I
tell you that you have something
like a singularity in the game the first
question going to come back with me is
well what's the cooldown on this right
well we don't have cooldowns in this
game right there's no man and no
cooldowns so instead you need over kills
to feed that synergy meter and when he
gets enough of these over kills he's
gonna have that singularity charged up
and he can lay it down so a really good
player that focuses hard on getting it
done is going to be able to pull them
off quite frequently so there's eight
different schools of magic in the game
we call them sigils and they're all very
very different from each other the
player sets himself up his build so to
speak is choosing three of these sigils
now in this case here josh has just
pulled off a singularity he sucks all
these enemies in and just detonates them
for devastating damage and again he can
continue to try to do that by over
killing and building his spells even
more powerful and playing even better so
this next area that he's moving into is
what we call loot rooms so our our
gameplay is a very tailored gameplay you
come into a map you make it way through
it to the other end and you move through
the story and these loot rooms are
different areas that reward the player
for exploration so when they come in and
they find these little optional areas
there's a machine bedded in the ground
and when you hit it with a spell like
josh is going to do here you start an
event and in this case there's a lot of
different very very ations of these in
the game in this particular case it
starts spawning enemies and as the
enemies come in their ways when you kill
them normally that loot that they drop
would come to the player and go into
your inventory but in this case when
you're in this loot machine challenge
the loot doesn't come to the player when
they die it goes up into the machine and
when it goes up into the machine as more
loot is added to the machine that can
keep promoting and rarity it can get
better and better
however the only way you're going to get
that loot is if you completely defeat
the encounter
so in some cases you'll look up at the
loot machine you'll see oh there's a
legendary in there but the only way
you're gonna get it is if you defeat the
encounter if you die you have to come
back in and try again
so you can see here Josh is convoying up
spells quite a bit and he's doing this
because he's trying knows the later
waves are much more challenging and he
wants to have a singularity or an ice
storm maybe to pull off to try to help
him defeat the waves the health system
for the game you can see in the lower
left corner there is a three-layered
shield and each one of those layers
works like other games you might expect
like Halo or Borderlands where you take
damage and as long as you don't lose the
whole layer it'll regenerate however as
you can see here josh has lost one layer
so he only has two left this enemy he's
fighting right here is the banshee and
she's not really that great of a damage
dealer but she's what we call a
distractor she'll scream and cause us
icy aura to emanate from her stunning
that the player you saw him frozen there
a moment ago so Josh should be looking
at his coming up in his final wave here
after he kills her
so as I mentioned we've got eight
different sigils in the game which are
spells schools there's seven different
ways to craft how you deliver those
spells there's things like the beam the
lob the missile and there you see he
pulled off a singularity right as he was
frozen and gets a pretty devastating
effect out of it so I think josh is
going to actually get through this wave
and not die
and there he goes gets all the loot from
the loot machine
so now josh is going to be advanced to
the boss and this is a new boss that we
just added in the early access release
and for this he's gonna switch back to
fire because he thinks he can be more
effective on the boss this way and he's
gonna craft himself see what he's gonna
do here he's gonna craft himself a flame
wall pattern so this is pretty cool this
is a legendary piece of loot that has
the flame wall affix and what that means
is every time he does a nova when he
blinks into enemies with the charge nova
he's gonna detonate a fire wall and
leave it persistent there to burn his
enemies and he can use it to hide behind
this particular map called the Maelstrom
when he comes in here he'll take a look
up you're at the bottom of a frozen
whirlpool that's called a wrecked ship
egde and everything that that has been
frozen in the water so we come down here
and we see the new boss that we've added
for our alpha release which again goes
live on Monday
and we have a nice large
crap boss here it spawns little enemies
that come out and explode so you can see
here are a lot of what we try to do is
we give you these tools to not only
deliver amazing awesome spells but it's
about the skill component of how do I
mix them together how do I utilize
lightning with fire and with ice in
order to deliver the best possible
attack another neat thing about our
bosses is if you how many times have you
played a game that you focus on a ice
build that's got all this freezing and
you can freeze enemies solid do this
amazing things and you get to the boss
and guess what you can't freeze them
well all crowd-control works on our
bosses however they don't like it so
that green bar you see at the bottom
that's an enraged meter as you see see
the boss he gets more and more angry and
when it becomes enraged he's immune to
crowd control for a period of time but
he also does more damage has special
attacks and is much more Signet much
more harder much more hard
so josh is using a lot of different
combos here see if you can pull off a
flame wall areas and now the boss is
sitting in a flame while burning so
again the game is going live in August
26 it's available on Steam right now in
early access for $19.99 on Monday when
it goes live on alpha it's going up in
price to $24.99 in five weeks on beta
it'll go to $29.99 and then unreleased
it'll be 39